dressed in white and displaying
patriotic symbols a thousand Colombians
marched through the capital of Bogota
with a long list of grievances against
the two months old government of Gustavo
Pedro
we are very worried by what's happening
in the country the crime and economic
insecurity the uncertainty with the text
political and electoral reforms that's
why entrepreneurs are fleeing the
country that's why the dollar is now
almost 5 000 pesos most of them are
metal and upper middle income Colombians
that could directly be affected by the
government's ambitious tax reform that
aims to raise almost 6 billion dollars
to fund social programs
others are workers of the oil and Mining
sector the fear Petrus promised to
accelerate the transition towards clean
energy
federal petrol's government has a
totally irresponsible Ultra
environmentalist position that pretends
to prematurely end one of the sectors
that contributes to most of the
country's economy that generates
hundreds of thousands of jobs
Pedro came into office following a wave
of discontent and demands for change in
a country deeply defined by social and
economic inequality
the ambitious agenda goes from seeking
total peace through deals with Rebel
groups and crime gangs to a series of
reforms to change the traditionally
market-friendly policies in the country
from Health to pensions to land reform
a recent polls show Petra's approval
fell from 56 to 46 percent mostly due to
concerns about the difficult economic
situation the honeymoon period has ended
but that not means that we are going to
see a separation or even a souring of
the relationship between the citizenry
and the current government I still think
that the current government has a large
political Capital to that will allow him
to operate at least for a year or more
organizers are calling for another
demonstration a week from now to keep
pressure on the government but to have
any chance to stop the reform from going
forward in Congress they will need to
mobilize a much larger number of
protesters Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota